another big story that we're following
tonight the eight news now high team
first with details on that deadly
shooting on the strip that shooting left
one man dead two women injured we've
learned the suspected shooter had tried
to kill the same man before our i-team's
david charns breaking the story last
night and updating us every step of the
way he joins us live in the mirage david
denise right now you wouldn't even know
there was a murder here less than 24
hours ago a murder that police say
happened on the eighth floor of the
mirage that suspected shooter shooting
and killing his cousin who has the same
name as a cousin the same suspect had
shot 20 years ago
from inside the casino we had no idea
visitors inside the mirage on thursday
night say they didn't know a suspected
shooter who had just killed his cousin
was on the run phone was blowing up with
texts that they couldn't get inside
there was a shooter potentially the 8
news now i-team first to identify the
suspect as 54-year-old billy hemsley
police say hemsley shot and killed his
cousin acturius milner inside a room on
the 8th floor after play fighting turned
bad hemsley also accused of shooting two
other women in that room and then
leaving the property police finding him
about six hours later at a bus stop
several miles away in the east valley
court records show hemsley served jail
time for shooting milner nearly 20 years
ago police called it an attempted murder
at the time hemsley later pleading
guilty to a charge of shooting another
human being in 2012 he was charged a
second time for attempted murder for a
stabbing involving a woman he knew
while police contained the eighth floor
and searched for their suspects security
briefly stopped people from entering the
building within a minute of the call
coming in a 911 call we had officers
already announcing that they're arriving
on scene everything was business as
usual in the casino but we could see
outside of the doors from our table and
there were a bunch of cop cars and cop
lights all flashing video from inside
showing the massive police response
possibly not rattling things inside was
maybe part of what they were trying to
accomplish and getting their hands on
this guy
hemsley is due in court tomorrow on that
murder charge and those latest charges
of attempted murder metro though
certainly doing a victory lap tonight
catching this suspect within just six
hours we're live outside the mirage i'm
david charns live local now